sí
conseguiste la aprobación final del
director felicidades
vimos que la traslación y el cambio de
escala no computan veamos y usando un
poco de álgebra podemos entender un poco
más qué es lo que está pasando
supongamos que hacemos una traslación de
5 en equis y 3 en jeff escoge un punto x
0 10/0 en la imagen que estamos
trasladando ese punto se va a otro punto
x uno de uno definido como el chis uno
igual a x 0 + 5 y de 1 igual a 10 0 3
supongamos que cambiamos la escala desde
el origen por un factor de 4 y adónde se
va el punto x 1 de 1 llamémosle x 2 de 2
al punto al que se va
el cambio de escala nos dice que x2 es
igual a 4 por x1
2 es igual a 4 porque 1 y ahora
sustituimos nuestras expresiones para x
1 ig1 entonces x 2 es igual a 4
x 05 lo cual es igual a 4 por x 0 + 4
por 5 y esto también es igual a 4 por x
0 + 20 y por otro lado de 2 es igual a 4
por 10 0 3 lo cual es igual a 4 porque 0
+ 12 este factor enfrente de x 0 ig0 es
4 así es que el factor de cambio de
escala sigue siendo 4 sin embargo la
traslación efectiva en x es 20 y la
traslación efectiva en g es 12 para
hacer una comparación realicemos las
operaciones en otro orden entonces
primero vamos a cambiar la escala x 1 es
igual a 4 por x 0
de 1 a 4 x 0 y luego hacemos la
traslación y entonces algebraica mente x
2 es igual a x 15 lo cual es igual a 4
por x 0
y jet2 es igual a 13 y entonces de 2 es
igual a 4 por 0 3 las ecuaciones azules
definitivamente no son iguales a las
ecuaciones rojas pero en ambos casos
estamos escribiendo la combinación del
cambio de escala con la traslación de
esta forma x 2 es igual a s por x 0 + tx
y jet2 es igual a s por 10 0 + thief
donde te x es la traslación efectiva o
sea la traslación final sobre x itei y
es la traslación efectiva sobre y cuando
dos transformaciones son más se combinen
les llamamos una transformación
compuesta en el próximo ejercicio te
vamos a pedir que verifique es que
siempre se mantiene esta fórmula general
para las transformaciones compuestas que
consisten en cambios de escala y
traslación es sin importar cuántas
traslación es y cuántos cambios de
escala combinemos
sin importar el orden